مثل ماركر كيزا رجل أريزونا الذي مات
بسبب فيروس كورونا في يونيو ،
تحدثت ابنته كريستين عن
وفاة والدها ، يجب أن أقول في مركز دبي الوطني
أن والدي كان يتمتع بصحة جيدة ويبلغ من العمر 65 عامًا وكان
حالته الوحيدة الموجودة مسبقًا هي
الوثوق في دونالد
ترامب ولهذا هو  لقد دفع
فيروس كورونا بحياته ، فقد أوضح أن هناك
أمريكيتين يعيش فيهما دونالد
ترامب ، والولايات المتحدة
التي توفي والدي فيها بما
يكفي ربما لم يكن دونالد ترامب قد
تسبب في الإصابة بفيروس كورونا ،
لكن خداعه وأفعاله غير المسؤولة
جعلت الأمر كذلك
كريستيان أو كيزا ينضم إلينا الآن
مسيحي ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على
انضمامك إلينا. كيف حالك أنت
وعائلتك الآن
ما هو سؤال صعب أه خاصة
عندما
نرى الرئيس يواصل التقليل من أهمية
الفيروس
قائلاً إن أحبائنا أممم.  لو لم يكن
أحدًا كان
الأمر صعبًا ، فلن أكذب لأننا نمر
بوقت عصيب ،
لا يمكنني القول إنني
لا أستطيع إلا أن أتخيل أنني في الواقع لا أستطيع
التخيل وأنا كذلك
خسارتك اليوم لقد اجتزنا معلمًا كئيبًا للغاية ،
أنا متأكد من أنك على دراية
بوفاة 200 ألف أمريكي من رئيس الفيروس هذا
بالكاد اعترف بذلك عندما
سئل عنه مباشرة ، قال
إنه من العار ما الذي
تريده.
للاستماع إلى رئيس
الولايات المتحدة هذا إذا كان أي شيء
أعنيه ، فإن الشيء الوحيد الذي
كنت أطلبه
هو استجابة وطنية منسقة تعتمد على البيانات
من هذا
الوباء ويستمر في إظهارنا مرارًا وتكرارًا
أنه يهتم فقط  عن نفسه صورته
ويبدو أن أصدقائه الأثرياء
قلتم إن أحد آخر ما
قاله والدك لك
هو أنه شعر بالخيانة من قبل دونالد
ترامب ،
هل يمكنك التحدث معي عن هذا
بالتأكيد قبل أن يذهب والدي إلى
المستشفى مباشرة سألت
هو عن شعوره تجاه الرئيس
وأبي وأنا تحدثنا عن السياسة
طوال الوقت
لم نتفق أبدًا على أي شيء ولكننا ما زلنا
نتحدث
عنه واه كانت نبرته مختلفة
، أخبرني أنه شعر بالضرب على الجانبين
وهو  هل تشعر بالخيانة وقال
نعم أشعر بالخيانة
وما قصده والدي بذلك هو أنه
صدق الرئيس
عندما قال إننا على
الجانب الآخر من
الوباء إذا لم يكن لديك
حالة صحية أساسية  كان من الآمن
استئناف
الأنشطة العادية ، كان والدي يفعل ما
يفعله الناس ويفترض أن يفعلوه في أوقات
الأزمات ،
فلنتبع توجيهات الأشخاص المسؤولين
ويجب ألا تضطر إلى الدفع بحياتك
مقابل ذلك